so auf geht's leute schauen wir mal ob ich heute
heute weniger husten muss ich habe jetzt gestern und heute wenn schon der chat sagt
wachst du hustest zu viel und muss hast hier zu trockenen hals und sowieso das hört sich nicht
gesund an da habe ich jetzt gestern eukalyptus dampfbad heute eukalyptus dampfbad ingwer
zitronen t salbei t mit honig ja ich habe es jetzt ich habe ich heute massig gesoffen also
was also flüssigkeit nicht also nicht besoffen sondern das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier alle fünf
minuten aufs klo muss dann liegt das da dran royal 117 dankeschön für den sub wenn viel zu
erfählen ab jetzt nö ich würde es nicht kaufen ganz ehrlich für alle die schon gekauft haben ja
da warum nicht warum nicht aus sack leute ich muss mal kurz was ich muss ich mal kurz ihr müsst mal
kurz ausgeplandet werden keck wait so ok jetzt dürfte wieder eingeplandet werden was zum teufel
sind ingwer schott sind das irgendwelche money boy memes oder sonst was da kennen wir nicht so
aus es ist tatsächlich dass das mit dem aktuellen patch stand ist es noch das spielbarste aber das
heißt nicht dass es gut spielbar ist um ehrlich zu sein es ist immer noch nicht gut spielbar und
rush wir spielen gleich noch ein paar runden rush rush ist halt auch übelst hingeklatscht
letztendlich das merkt man auch zum beispiel gibt es keine runden switch am ende desinfiziert
den haus sehr gut die frage ist ja ich glaube nicht dass ich krank bin ich glaube einfach ich
habe viel zu trockenen haus und deswegen muss ich mich räuspern vor allem husten und das ist halt
im stream kacke weiß nicht ob das dafür so gut ist weil es soll ja eigentlich geschmeidig
machen ich rauche nicht wisst ihr auch hoffe ich mal gehe ich mal von aus dass das eigentlich bekannt
ist dass ich nicht rauche ich habe noch nie geraucht das einzige wo ich mal wo ich mal dran
gezogen haben war als ich irgendwie keine ahnung 15 war oder so da habe ich dann irgendwie zwei drei
tagen war versucht so eine zigarette zu ziehen und einmal habe ich auch eingeatmet und ab übelst
gehustet hat mir gedacht warum macht man so einen scheiß und dann habe ich nie wieder eine zigarette
angefasst in meinem leben ohne scheiß nun nie mehr danach warum totaler schwachsinn
und auch wenn ich für 20 legalisierung bin in deutschland heißt nicht dass ich mir da öfters
was gönne aber ich finde es bescheuert zigaretten und schnapps und sowas zu erlauben und vor 20
nicht mal und sage ich ja ja ja das stimmt mit der lautstärke nicht jetzt seck
die lautstärke ist den richtigen müssen sie lauter machen für bettel viel gleich
und da müssen wir die musik ein bisschen leiser machen sonst ist es zu laut
exzellent so ist das richtig ja das stimmt deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum es immer
noch so viele raucher gibt weil wenn man sich sowas eklig ist antrainieren muss was
nur ein von nachteil ist und geld kostet warum macht man es dann ja so ungefähr ist das wenn
man den scheiß das erste mal einatmet also ich habe ich habe danach auch nie das verlangen
verspürt ja mag sein das habe ich vor lauter husten wahrscheinlich nicht bemerkt weißt du
was die neue option mit der schadensanzeige farbe ich weiß gar nicht dass er neue option gibt ich
weiß nur dass viele jetzt auf farben plinth modus spielen weil das anscheinend irgendwie
neues meta ist oder so kein schimmer weiß ich nicht habe ich mich nicht mit weiter beschäftigt
ich ich werde eh nur rush spielen in nächster zeit falls ich überhaupt noch großartig spiele
weil alles andere halte ich nicht aus farben plinth war schon immer meta ja das stimmt
habe ich die richtige kategorie benefit 42 ja stimmt heute hat mich jemand gefragt also
einer von den online kumpels hat mich gefragt heute max erzähl noch mal was dein schlimmstes
date war da habe ich mir gedacht alle was das für ein thema habe ich mir gedanken gemacht
habe ich gut so ultra viele waren das jetzt ja nicht die vor allem war die meisten auch mega
weird champ aber aber eins ist mir eingefallen was quasi so das eigentlich das beste und das
schlimmste in einem war ich glaube da mache ich mal ein video drüber weil über solche themen
mache ich normalerweise nie videos da kann man ab und zu mal was zu sagen
morgen gibt es amerikan football und pizza na dann wieso weil morgen nikolaus es gibt
amerikan football oder ist das super bowl oder sowas das ist ja kokona hoch hoch 500
während ich das spiel starte erzähle ich euch das auch mal kurz dass ihr nicht auf das video
warten müsst also aber starten hyper hyper bowl ist das noch ein zweiter als super bowl weiß gar
nicht was war der letzte grill story die ich erzählen haben mit mit der auszeit aus dem
türkeiurlaub oder was war das was jetzt weiß ich kann über was im video erzählt hat also
erzählt dann ist die leute die kurzfassung die kurzfassung also mein bestes und schlechtestes
date in kombination ich habe eine über damals das war das ist rock das war irgendwie rock am
ring 2003 oder so das ist wirklich lange her das ist da das ist da wo ich auch mal vor
jahren unter so einem nickelback video kommentierte aber auf youtube dass man mich im publikum sieht
und zumindest ich habe eine über den mmo damals kennengelernt das war da war ich quasi meiner
zeit voraus heute ist es ja normal dass man leute online kennenlernt aber damals war das nicht
unbedingt so über ein mmo und was sonst mmo ich war ja schon 24 sieben am rechner stellst
wurde wo lernt man dann sonst medels kennen ja in einem mmo zumindest wir haben wir haben
da wir haben da ewig rumgeschrieben und telefoniert und gemacht und getan und irgendwann haben wir
gesagt leute oder lasst lasst uns doch mal treffen und wie wäre es denn wenn wir einfach zusammen
rock am zu rock am ring fahren was was im nachhinein eigentlich super weird champ idee ist mit einem
den du nicht wirklich kennst erst mal drei tage rock am ring aber ok ok rock am ring mein fader
hat mich hingefahren das weiß ich noch mein fader mich also wir haben die abgeholt sind dann mit
der hingefahren und an sich war das wirklich geil ich war davor noch nie auf dem festival in dieser
größe und ich habe das ich habe das übelst übelst abgefeiert das war auch so die die zeit wo bei rock
am ring teilweise noch so emo musik liegt so emo musik lief so effervescence und sowas zumindest
irgendwie 2003 oder so muss das gewesen sein weiß ich schon eine ganze weile her und zumindest das
war aus dem grund gut weil es halt nice ist und ich halt noch nie vorher auf so einem festival
gewesen bin ich habe auch mein rucksack verloren mit taschenlampe drin alles weil ich so helga
genau helga das kam da auch auf helga so zumindest wir waren auf einem dieser zeltplätze es gibt ja
auch noch die möglichkeit dass man ein bisschen weiter auf so einen campingplatz geht wir waren
halt wie die noobs zeltplätze hatten so einen so einen an einem also das war ein bisschen an
nicht wirklich ein groß also kein hang aber es ging ein bisschen bergab wo wir den zeltplatz anlassen
bis permanent runter gerutscht das war eh schon war eh schon pains champ zumindest eigentlich haben
wir uns ganz gut verstanden aber ich habe okay hätte er schlechter laufen können ja also wir haben
es quasi das erste mal dann so real life gesehen so bei denen im haus wo ich es abgeholt habe wo
man dann richtung rock rock am ring gefahren sind so zumindest jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt richtig
richtig pelsen gleich wobei in den ersten mal kommen durch coolen sachen also erstens rock
am ring rock am ring war richtig nice was nikel beck war am start das weiß ich noch die toten
hosen waren am stand habe ich damals voll drauf gestanden es war dann trotzdem so da lasst mal
überlegen alle haben irgendwie metallica gekovert was ich nicht verstanden habe metallica war nicht
aber alle haben sie metallica gekovert aus irgendwelchen gründen wahrscheinlich weil
es bei den in der in der menge gut angekommen ist na zumindest fand ich fand ich übelst geil
so dann haben wir abends im zelt gehockt und das erste das jetzt weiß ich auch warum ich
wieder drauf gekommen bin das erste was ich mitbekommen habe als wenn im zelt im zelt abends sind
das erste was ich mitbekommen habe ist die macht das zelt wieder auf und macht erst mal eine runde
web nation die packt sich erst mal ihr zeug aus und und furtelt sich da in den joint zusammen und
ich habe dann damals ihr müsst wissen also ich habe es ja so mit mit mit real life kontakten
und so nicht ich bin da ich bin ja auch schon weird champ was das angeht zumindest ich hatte
dann permanent bedenken dass sie irgendwie das zelt abfackelt weil die saß da halt gerade
angemacht hat immer mal ein bisschen was weiß ich irgendwie nachge nachgefeuert oder was man da
macht ich dachte alle die tut gleich das tut gleich das zelt an dann hat sie sich zu mir umgekehrt
so willst du auch mal willst du auch mal so ne ne ne ne lass mal lass mal alles gut nehmen was
hau du dir nur rein ich brauch dich und da hatte ja erst mal voll ein abgekifft am eingang vom zelt
quasi aus dem zelt raus die hälfte ist ins zelt reingezogen vielleicht habe ich auch ein bisschen
von eingeatmet habe dann minimalste wirkung bekommt keine ahnung zumindest nachdem wir da
am zelt nachdem die halt sich dann irgendwie in joint reingezogen hat da bist da wirst halt
anscheinend super super entspannt und anhänglich vermute ich mal dass es daran lag zumindest hat
die sich übelst an mich range schmissen nachdem die das sich sich sich rein reingezogen hat also
ich wusste nichts machen ich musste einfach nur anwesend sein ich wusste einfach nur anwesend
sein also so wenig anstrengungen habe ich glaube ich noch noch nie noch nie aufbringen müssen das
was geht zumindest naja ok ja also das war so kontakt mit anderen menschen hatte ich ja eh
nicht mehr sein aufgefallen auch wie nervig die anderen leute auf dem auf dem festival sind und
so und leute ich sag euch in dem also es ist es ist hardcore wirtschamp in dem zelt wo man
irgendwie denkt es ist es ist es ist dunkel du hast natürlich drum drum herum bisschen leute
haben teilweise lagerfeuer gemacht so ganz merklich was du eigentlich nicht durftest zumindest es
ist ganz merkwürdig also es ist ultra wirtschamp in so einem zelt wo man ja eigentlich denkt man
ist alleine aber drum herum liegen irgendwie in anderen zellten irgendwie keine ahnung 500
leute es ist also ok es war auf jeden fall äußerst wirtschamp egal also ich muss mich da null anstrengen
dafür ich muss einfach nur anwesend sein und gegen was alles klar zumindest das ist dann die
anfängliche wie soll ich sagen so die anfängliche euphorie wie soll es auch anders sein ja also
geiles festival und hier gatchibas und alles mögliche zumindest am anderen tag war dann
halt das problem und das war schon das war schon der dritte tag weil ich weiß dass das muss sonntag
gewesen sein ja das ist glaube ich drei tage waren es nur zwei tagen ich bin verwirrt ist auch egal
zumindest am nächsten tag wurde es dann richtig wirtschamp da hatte ich sich total besoffen was
man ja auch so festivals macht aber halt richtig extrem zumindest hatte ich sich dann so besoffen
dass man dass die eigentlich gar nicht mehr irgendwie groß hat dass wir gar nicht da irgendwie uns
musik anhören konnten oder sowas die war einfach nur besoffen und musste dann kotzen und hat noch
dünnschiss bekommen ist kein jetzt wird es abartig leute die hat dann dünnschiss bekommen da habe
ich gesagt okay lass mal zum zelt zurück leg dich mal hin und dann hat die dünnschiss bekommen da
mussten die laufen kacken und dann ist die in wald und ist in wald kacken gegangen hat festgestellt
ja kein klopapier dann saß die im wald und hat dann so geschrien nach mir ich soll klopapier
bringen und da musste ich der bestimmt fünf sechs mal klopapier in den wald bringen weil
die da am kacken war und das war schon äußerst wirtschamp und eklig also das hat sich so um 180
grad gewendet ich habe jetzt eigentlich fast schon ein bisschen vermutet wir gehen jetzt ins zelt
und weiter gehts ja aber nein es wird erstmal geschissen zumindest ich war eh schon komplett
komplett über überfordert mit der ganzen situation ja so viele fremde leute und und
alles alles zusammen von außen sonst wie und dass ich dann auch noch klopapier bringen musste in
wald zu einen dünnschiss hat da habe ich mir gedacht das geht jetzt nicht dann habe ich dann habe ich
richtig richtig wie sagt man so den den dreckser move gemacht oder so ich weiß nicht wie man das
wie man das ausdrücken kann ich habe dann gesagt alle ich halte es hier nicht mehr aus und ich
habe dann damals mein vater angerufen und gesagt hier kannst du mich abholen ich weiß eigentlich
erst heute heute abend aber ich muss hier weg und dann dann ist ist er halt hingefahren und
eigentlich war der plan gewesen wir nehmen die wieder mit mit heim oder so und ich habe die dann
quasi auf dem festival sitzen lassen und bin heim gefahren richtig oberspannenden ruf all das
zumindest die war danach berechnigterweise richtig richtig angepisst und die hat mich dann instant
icq geblockt in game unfriended und ich habe noch nie ich hatte auch wirklich ich hatte dann
auch echt schlechtes gewissen muss ich sagen ich habe die dann auch von mir aus nicht mehr
angeschrieben und ich habe nie wieder auch nur ein virtuelles wort mit der gewechselt danach
das war so wirklich mein bestes und schlechtes ist der gleichermaßen aber 2003 das auch schon
minimal her ja ok wir spielen jetzt eine runde battlefield hallo warte fack ach nee ich muss
jetzt umschalten weil sonst wiederum leckt so viel geben wir mal ein oder captain progas
ist da der captain progas den feld land war eine captain progas land war ein weil sonst noch
einer von euch mitmachen will leute am besten wenn ich euch schon in origin habsach bescheid
hat sie schon verdient ich weiß nicht ich meine die hat sie auf die warte ja doch auch keine ahnung
wie das also abgeht aber die hat schon auf dem festival besoffen und ich hätte eigentlich
darauf aufpassen müssen dass sie zumindest wieder halbwegs so sicher heimkommen ich habe
mich einfach verpisst das war schon das war schon cringe ja aber sollste machen ich ich hab es da
echt nicht mehr ausgehalten ich wusste ich weiß noch ich habe alle was ist hier los so viel leute
so viel krach eine die im wald sitzen und dünnschiss hatten ich muss klopapier ich will weg und da
war ich halt nicht sonderlich selbstlos sondern sehr egoistisch hab ich gesagt soll ich lass
mich jetzt abholen ich verpiss mich ach ist das heute der sigma chat move so so ich weiß ja nicht
machst du mal wieder was zum esp 2866 ja gibt bestimmt wieder demnächst was zum basteln alles
klar soll ich spiele eine runde rush basteln alter und ich war mal kurz die nintendo musik aus müssen
gleich mal schauen ob die lautstärke stimmt keppenpoggers schon die ganze zeit da ja moin
leute also schön dass so viele neue leute wieder den weg her gefunden haben ich werde wahrscheinlich
wir die hälfte an subscribten sonst wird es übersehen oh nein schlimmste map von allen
der fatal hat auch ein abo gegiftet an den frozen bullet mit dem vorhin zusammengespielt
alles dankeschön und auch den ganzen follows hier am start leute heute übrigens ziel erreicht
meilenstein erreicht auf youtube 290.000 abonnenten es fehlen jetzt bloß noch 10.000 bis 300.000 das
kriegen wir nächstes jahr auf jeden fall hin wenn ich nicht wieder in der versenkung verschwinde
mit videos kennst du noch was kleines als der esp 2866 welcher auch will der esp 2866 guck dir
mal den esp01 an das ist auch in esp 2866 der ist ziemlich klein du brauchst ja nicht diese
entwickler bords wenn du du brauchst ja eigentlich nur den chip so auf geht's ah wir sind attacker
sehr gut sehr gut attack stellt auf geht's so lasst mal kurz laut alter was war das fünf fp
es laut screen oder was lautstärke müsste passen
ich glaube das werde ich mal ein bisschen ausführlicher in dem video erzählen weil
auf der einen seite ist es eine lustige story und außerdem sage ich zu solchen themen sehr
wenig gibt ja auch nicht viel was ich da großartig erzählen kann aber das glaube ich mal ganz
witzige abwechslung zumal ich eh schon viel zu viel battlefield stels gemacht haben letzter
zeit guck mal hier bunny hop stels seht ihr das borgas wisst ihr wie das funktioniert wenn ihr
es nicht wisst kann ich kann ich mal hier bunny hop guide machen gleich alter
da werden sie gesprayt nein nein das war verbeacht der andere war das der andere war das nice also
ich sag mal was zu dieser bunny hopping geschichte hop hop champ lautstärke ist ok oder lautstärke
müsste eins passen hopp gem nicht pock gem hopp gem also kommt man muss ihr müsst einfach
folgendes machen ihr schießt das ding irgendwo dran und dann lasst ihr alle tasten los und
spammt lehrtaste ihr dürft bloß keine richtung drücken auf fack ich weiß nicht ob das ein bug
ist oder oder was das ist keine ahnung aber das ist ja praktisch wahrscheinlich ist es ein bug
in dem spiel weiß in dem game kannst du dir nichts also nicht sicher sein im endeffekt also ob das
ein bug ist oder gewollt das weiß man ja nicht hat dein vater da nichts gesagt wo sie nicht mit
gefahren ist doch ich hab dem das erzählt so ansatzweise und ich weiß nicht mal was er genau
gesagt hat oder so aber ich glaube er hat gelacht und irgendwie so was so nach dem motto ja wusste
ich schon dass die nervig ist oder irgendwie so was um mich zu beruhigen weil ich war echt
bisschen bisschen mitgenommen so ich hätte es dir gleich sagen können oder was in der
richtung eigentlich auch komplett verantwortungslos aber das würde ich von dem auch nicht anders
erwarten also mit verantwortung hat das eh nicht so gab was fährt denn hier rum
bei der wei wer diese map designed hat ist mir komplett ein rätsel na guckt euch das mal an
du musst komplett übers offene feld rennen massive bunny hopping mal hier das ist einfach
offen o lasst mich in ruhe a nice auf fack
hier kommt ganz schön viel jetzt oder da kommt der pence man der pence man das ist der nächste
keppen pokas ist wieder weg oder hin das ganze spiel ist hier ein rätsel chat mir auch
mir auch das sind alles ist enemies ok und jetzt guckt man wo man spawned lull was ist
sonst wo das ist schon wird fällt euch übrigens der richtig gute soundtrack auf in dem spiel
hört ihr ihn auch gerade richtig hat die richtig geile soundtrack oder also der kick richtig
der pence man ist am start
wie viel spielzeit schon ich glaube 55 stunden oder so ich weiß auch nicht warum ich so viel
spielzeit im spiel habe water game wir hätten das game nächstes jahr ausbringen sollen ja
kann er kann er pence man sich mal verpissen gerade es ist möglich was ist denn jetzt los
habt ihr das auch gerade gesehen das ist doch nicht normal ich kann übrigens gerade nicht
raus habt ihr gesehen wie der sich geblieben hat gerade wir haben es ich habe keine keine
muni mehr das ist doof du stehst wohl auf schmerzen du meinst weil ich das game so viel
spiele ja das stimmt wohl weiß auch nicht was mit mir los ist eigentlich komplett unsinnig
ich glaube da ist jemand da ist jemand beim diffusen ja ja die muni ist leer die maps
sind viel zu groß selbst 128 spieler ja deswegen spiele ich ja gern 16 versus 16 weil 16 versus
16 hat noch nicht hinten in der x-born können 16 versus 16 hat noch überschaubar irgendwo
ist seht ihr mal guckt euch mal die häuser an das ist guck mal die beleuchtung ist einfach
mal krass im arsch also allen ernstes dice was das hier also guckt euch das mal an und
dann sind da drin irgendwelche komischen farbeimer das war es was ist das für ein haus hier
guckt euch das mal an das sieht aus wie den level designer der gerade das erste mal den
den world edit in half life aufgemacht hat oder so und jetzt kommen die leute unter youtube
gesagt max du willst nur das spiel halten das spiel ist eigentlich richtig gut wenn
ihr nicht alle sagen würde dass das spiel schlecht es würde es keiner merken ganz klar
natürlich was sonst es sind eindeutig die leute den fehler benennen dran schuld nicht
die leute den fehler programmiert haben oder dies nicht programmiert haben besser gesagt
und die map begrenzung sind auch komplett random
hier ist noch einer oder auch nicht keiner da doch der pence man ist da der gegner pence
man übrigens ich wurde muss ich euch nachher mal zeigen ich wurde belehrt unter dem letzten
letzten video wo ich gesagt habe rush ist ruckelts eigentlich oder ist gut ich muss mal kurz
selbst in meiner vorschau gucken ob alles ok ist ich glaube es alles ok oder chat bin
mir nicht sicher meine vorschau meine vorschau weiß es selber nicht so genau ich gucke mir
das grad mal vom handy in der vorschau an dann ist vielleicht besser tipptopp ok nice
da sieht man wieder das spiel ist einfach nicht fertig wäre auch mal nice wenn man
bei rush mal aufsätze drauf machen könnte was meinste wie bei rush aufsätze drauf ich
drehe mich mal kurz im kreis moment ich drehe mich mal schnell im kreis da sehe ich nämlich
ob es flüssig ist ja ist alles gut alles super flüssig passt ich habe es jetzt in der vorschau
gesehen ok nice warum das stream auf 48 fps ist weil 48 fps die big brain fps variante
ist das ist die beste kombi alles klar spiel sehr gut hat nicht registrat weil 48 fps die
optimale kombination ist aus bildqualität pro bild und flüssig für smoothness only
five head will know weißt du übrigens ich habe gestern mal die k30 anlockt weil im letzten
weil im letzten stream haben viele geschrieben nach dem motto max zeigt doch kann kann das
mal hinten please max zeigt doch mal please die k30 und wisst ihr wie lange ich gebraucht
habe um alle attachments zu anlocken für die k30 ratet mal ratet mal wie lange habe ich
gebraucht 300 kills 300 kills ist das höchste eine runde korrekt ja zwanzig minuten oder
so kennt ihr den waffen level trick auf kaleidoskop oder soll ich den mal zeigen gleich wahrscheinlich
kennt er aber mittlerweile ist schon jeder wo ist denn hier überhaupt irgendwas moment
map wo bin ich chat wo bin ich ach hier unten da gibt genug videos ja also man kann in kaleidoskop
aufs dach sich hinter hinter eine luftschacht hinter eine luftschacht stelzen und sich
hinlegen und die bots in die füße schießen und die bots retten sich zeigt den ok mache
ich dann ich schreib sie mal kurz auf aber ich mache jetzt erst noch ein paar runden
so weil sonst muss ich ja party des bänden so zumindest kaleidoskop legt man sich in
der luftung schacht und die bots laufen darum und haben keinen plan was passiert und du
schießt ihnen in fuß und dann machst du fünf oder zehn bots machst du platt und wartest
bis die bots sich wieder gerest haben und dann machst du wieder zehn bots platt und
dann hast du so in zwanzig minuten die komplette waffe anlockt ungefähr zwanzig minuten ob
das so gedacht ist keine ahnung aber was mich stutzig macht ist dass man den portal immer
noch nicht richtig xp bekommen kann obwohl das möglich ist zumal ihr waffen anlocken
eines der unspaßigsten sachen hier im battlefield ist also das wundert mir jetzt würde ich
jeder waffe machen die ich spielen will die stellsten da oben rum ich habe ich habe schiss
dass ich jetzt hier gleich gefahrt werde aber haben wir keine hitmarker bekommen kann das
sein du fragst dich was doch kaka boom heute macht also ich weiß nicht inwieweit ich das
im detail erzählen darf deswegen sage ich noch mal sehr grob der ist bei einem deutschen
automobil hersteller und macht da big brain fließband optimierung ich liebe in diesem
game dass nix stirbt über range alles weg weggesprayt achtung hüpfen hüpfen das war's
schon ich dachte man muss noch hinten in die hinten in die hochhäuser rein wahrscheinlich
haben die sich gedacht die leute haben uns so geflammt wegen breakthrough flaggen auf dem
dach wir lassen das jetzt einfach aus angel das it again die spröche die ich bekomme
da nicht drauf klar liest man optimierung ist das passende profil um sich bei her zu
bewerben ja schon ein bisschen ok während das jetzt neues match sucht lese ich meine
runde chat ja ja ich weiß ich weiß meinst du das habe ich vergessen oder ja das mit
den round time ist auch vorbei das ist quasi verkehr darum hat glaube ich 15 minuten gedauert
von einer stunde und der sagt 45 da sieht man ja wie kaputt das ist übrigens da muss
ich jetzt an der stelle auch noch mal sagen ist ja dass mich das schon ein bisschen traurig
macht dass battlefield so in die battlefield formel ist das gelb mittlerweile gut nein
eigentlich unverwüstlich ist im kern aber man hat so viel in battlefield 2042 verschlimm
bessert dass es einfach nur ein schatten seiner selbstes selbst selbst in rush also
wie soll ich sagen also man merkt schon dass in battlefield immer noch ein ziemlich gutes
game sein könnte aber halt bf 2042 hat er drumherum so viel verkackt dass es halt wirklich
nur das absolute minimum da ist und sogar das minimum macht noch spaß jetzt kommt die
map mit m.com auf dem dach wahrscheinlich wirklich auch kaleidoskop leute also ich wurde
ich wurde darüber belehrt in meinem video das kaleidoskop total unbalanced ist aber
unbalanced für die defender also die defender haben es total einfach das hochhaus schwach
sind sorry sorry falsch rum also für die attacker die attacker haben es angeblich total einfach
das hochhaus einzunehmen sagen sagen youtube kommentare also in wirklichkeit habe ich das
einfach nur nicht verstanden wir gucken uns jetzt mal an wie einfach das ist gleich das
hochhaus soll total einfach einzunehmen sein ach ja und und die begründung ist die begründung
ist anscheinend gibt es ein klitsch wer hätte das gedacht wo man den defenders den heli klauen
kann ich weiß nicht ob ein klitsch eine gute begründung ist für balance aber gut youtube
kommentare sind sind einfach too way way too smart für mich diese hipfire akurasi aber
ich habe noch mario musik an sekunde mal kurz mal oder soll ich mario musik anlassen ich
lasse mal die mario musik an im hintergrund weil das fack das spiel hat ja kein kein
soundtrack wir hören uns einfach ein bisschen mario wintermusik an was halten wir davon
immer noch besser als gar kein soundtrack ok so war das nicht geplant meine leute sind
dead da komme ich nicht hin der captain poggers ist wieder da poggers ich habe den gesehen
ich dachte ich dachte ich komme noch um die ecke ist das eigentlich real mit den shotguns
ne das aqua video habe ich nicht gesehen dass die also ich wurde schon schon ich wurde
teilweise von shotguns across map gehütet aber keine ahnung was er in dem video sagt
übrigens es gibt irgendwie keinen richtigen respawn timer falls ihr es gesehen habt also
was hier los der kommt gleich achtung da kommt gleich einer um die ecke oder auch nicht
nach da ist er ja auto shotgun mit slug ernsthaft das muss man ausprobieren da haben wir doch
gleich was nachher wenn ich euch das zeige wie man am besten waffen anlockt mit dem mit
diesem kaleidoskop klitsch können wir gleich die auto shotgun anloggen achtung hoi hoi
hoi einfach nur 400 meter laufen das ist ja nix sniper shotgun ich weiß nicht was es
den battlefield mit den shotguns so auf sich hat aber aus irgendwelchen gründen sind die
shotguns selten shotguns sondern manchmal sogar die besseren sniper das war ein bett
company 2 schon so das war ein battlefield teilweise so kein schimmer was mit den los
ist ungepatchte euer usas frags das war ein battlefield 3 auch so ein ding usas frags
passt mal auf das sieht man auch wie undurchdacht es ist dass es sich nicht am auto auto festhängt
sondern in der luft bleibt und so wait what keck wait achtung lass mich hinten dran da
ist von der seite mw2 akimbo model euer richtig poc ich sag euch ich sag euch mal wie es ist
ich habe in mw2 akimbo shotguns gespielt obwohl es op war und ich habe glaube ich sogar gameplays
hochgeladen mit akimbo shotgun warum auch nicht das sind schneiber tut da nix hittet ok ich
bin mir nicht so ganz sicher achtung achtung big brain move ich höre gegen schneiber dudes
man vielleicht kriege ich auch nicht der fatal ist auch dauernd shit g18 g18 akimbo war auch
poc b90 akimbo kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern also ich kann mich in mw2 ich kann
mich an model akimbo erinnern das war das krasseste überhaupt model akimbo spaß spaß
war das beste leute spaß zwölf sandy ravage können wir euch noch an sandy ravage erinnern
die stehen aber auch in jeder ecke gerade double kill sandy ravage war poc ich glaube
jeder wollte damals gameplays machen so wie sandy ravage oder kommt da herangestellts
krasse poggers medic game pass mal auf ich zeige euch jetzt mal den besten camp spot
für defender hier drin der beste camp spot für defender hier leute besser camp spot wenn
ihr denkt hier wenn ihr denkt das geht nicht besser die rennen hier rein die hier oben check
nie jemand hier check nie jemand ja zwar nicht so einfach alles klar ok das war keine so
big break crepel action die waffe ist so krass aus der hüfte also ich muss sagen jetzt mal
so vergleich m9 k30 die waffen sind beide ziemlich gut weil die ich will mit übrigens
easy angeblich ist es total einfach das jetzt einzunehmen hier also mein chat mein chat
hat gesehen eben nicht mein chat mein meine youtube comments haben gesagt das ist total
easy die einzunehmen also ihr guckt euch wir werden wir werden uns jetzt angucken dass
das total easy ist habe ich vergessen was ich vorher sagen wollte also die k30 kiltert
ein bisschen schneller auf close range wobei die m9 auch schnell ist aber die k30 ist über
range nicht so gut guck mal die haben heli das ist übrigens gar kein problem es ist
total easy oder findet ihr nicht auch dass es ganz einfach ist da hinzukommen eigentlich
ob obviously easy just take the objective youtube kommentare feels dank man ja ich hab ich ja
glück oder nice a spawn nice a spawn wir brauchen da mal ok anscheinend ist doch easy easy leute
das ist doch easy ich hab nix gesagt es ist easy easy das ist acht oder kommt gleich einer
von den easy ok anscheinend ist es doch easy gut also ich hab nix gesagt die youtube comments
hatten doch recht es ist easy und tschüss ich verpiss mich mal ich fahre einfach wieder
hoch die musik passt perfekt die musik passt richtig gut oder wie so hängt das stream hängt
das stream sollte nicht hängen ich gucke mal schnell stats nö wir haben keinerlei render
und keinerlei frame drops ich glaube das war eben easy weil wir einfach schneller waren
was auch nicht also ganz ehrlich es ist auch eine schlechte balance wenn die fänder nicht
vor den attackern am mkomm sind ich hatte sechs hipfire kills ja endlich endlich habe ich
das mal geschafft ich arbeite schon die ganze zeit auf hipfire kills hin jetzt habe ich
endlich mal selbst sechs hipfire kills geschafft das ist das größte achievement das game
ist gecrasht das game ist rip leute das game ist einfach gecrasht also fatal ich join dir
gleich rein bleib mal drin ich will attacker bleiben death operator dank für den sub einfach
game komplett crash arena gemacht sollst du pause waren ich habe vorher schon pause gemacht
und richtig schön richtig schön pepo fett gefuttert bevor ich den stream angeschmissen
habe beste musik für battlefield ja passt wir könnten ich glaube wir könnten die musik
nur noch toppen nur noch toppen mit moment nur noch hier mit toppen rechtsklick join
das ist auch ziemlich ppega joein q 3 von 3 2 von 3 ok wir müssen eh kurz warten aber
lieber das hier ja gut solange wir noch in der q sitzen kann ich auch mal kurz chat lesen
trap jaw danke für den sub auch die battlefield 5 beta da war da weiß ich auch da bin ich
auch ein bisschen durchgedreht und ich dachte es ist ja so schlimm ich habe battlefield
1 kaum gespielt obwohl es quasi noch eines der besseren der letzten jahre war einfach
weil mir das alles nicht so richtig zugesagt hat dann kam battlefield 5 und ich dachte
mehr das könnte mal wieder cool werden im zweiten weltkrieg habe ich mir dann gekauft
auch kaum gespielt hätte ich gewusst was mit battlefield 2042 auf mich zukommt dann
hätte ich ich hätte wirklich tausende stunden gekreidet in diesen games weil es die letzten
battlefield gewesen wäre die man noch gescheit spielen konnte vielleicht sollte ich mal vielleicht
sollte ich mal wieder demnächst leute chat was sagt ihr wollen wir demnächst mal wieder
battlefield 3 und 4 anschmeißen q 2 von 2 alles klar weiß q champ ja ja können wir machen
battlefield 3 ja poc erx machen wir so paar runden paar runden russ paar runden konquest
können wir echt mal machen ich wollte auch ein video machen auf youtube so zurück zu
battlefield 3 aber ich mache erst mal eins zwei technik videos ich muss auch mal wieder
ein stellenanzeigen video machen weil es haben ich ja auch viele so ein bisschen für it
geschichten abonniert und das ist ja eigentlich auch ein thema ich will es ja auch so ein
bisschen zweigleisig weitermachen und ich habe schon viel zu viel battlefield letzter
zeit gebracht ja die heli ist ich würde da auch maps spielen wo nicht so viel heli
stellts am start ist ich bin in battlefield 3 eigentlich auch kaum air maps also ich spiele
kein firestorm kein kake island oder so kann ich mal in die please die queue poppen jetzt
wenn es oder normal normal wenn es ist ja keiner mehr keiner mehr am start wir können mal
schnell in wenn es gucken wie viel also während ich hier in der queue sitze wir gucken mal
kurz in wenn es habe ich das deinstalliert nach dem v u klein ist das ding hyper subschreiber
michael 50 milliard dankeschön für den sub ja ja schauen wir mal kurz nebenbei rein
wie viele leute da drauf sind wahrscheinlich ist der meistbesuchte server drei stück
fünf stück war nice massive so also besser geht es ja nicht was ist denn jetzt hier los
ja warum warum poppt die queue nicht der desktop der desktop ist massive poggers jeder da
sagt er dass dieser desktop unordentlich ist er überblickt das chaos einfach nicht only
feifert leute nose ja golm und welts außen heli stellts paradies kann ich dir ein bild